hey a we by we I mean Pat and I took the
political compass sort of test I guess
we would call it ethical compass org
this is not a perfect test of one's
political alignment but it is
interesting and it puts you on a matrix
sort of from left to right and from
authoritarian to libertarian and I
actually took this test on the show in
2012 so when a second we'll compare
whether my politics have changed over
the last five years let's first take a
look at a few things starting with the
2016 primaries okay as you can see in
the primaries you had the Republican
candidates basically fully on the
right-wing authoritarian side you had
Hillary Clinton still in the right-wing
authoritarian quadrant and then you had
Bernie Sanders sort of on the left-right
between authoritarian and libertarian in
the general election you then saw a
combination of Donald Trump fully
authoritarian and quite right according
to the political compass test Hillary
Clinton less authoritarian than Donald
Trump but still relatively conservative
politically you had Gary Johnson who was
also on the right politically but much
more libertarian than authoritarian and
then you had Jill Stein over on the Left
libertarian quadrant of the graph
historical figures that we can show you
and how they would have placed on this
graph we're showing Joseph Stalin would
have been a left authoritarian Hitler
would have been extremely authoritarian
more right than left Margaret Thatcher
less authoritarian than Hitler but more
right and then we have I'm guessing
that's is that Milton Friedman
presumably as a historical figure who
would have been very right but more
libertarian and then Gandhi would have
been a left libertarian okay so how did
I do
let's start with that first what I want
to show you is this is my result when I
took this in 2012 and as you can see
grainy old picture from the old David
Pakman show episodes before we were in
high definition you see that I was a
left libertarian left libertarian and
now
compared to my new results I have
changed my politics slightly and I've
become slightly more left and slightly
more libertarian over the last five
years Pat also took this test
here's Pat's result and as you can see
Pat slightly more authoritarian than me
slightly more right than me noticing how
about that this isn't a perfect test
right but it does assess some pretty
important aspects of someone's overall
worldview and it is interesting that
over five years I mean these are slight
differences but basically my politics
have not changed over the five years
right and there's also four options
there there's agree strongly agree
strongly disagree and disagree right so
we could agree or disagree on a lot of
the same things there but depending on
how strongly we do so that's what kind
of skew the results a little bit there's
a reddit thread with lots of our viewers
taking the political compass org test
and then posting their results and a lot
of our viewers are pretty widely all
over the map I encourage people to check
that out at david pakman.com slash read
it take it yourself and also post it
it's pretty interesting to see the range
of views in our audience yeah I'd love
to do another one too because I mean
there's some questions here that you
don't really associate too much with
politics like for example when you're
upset about something is it best to pay
attention to that or to get your mind
off it and think of different things is
that really political it's not obviously
political in terms of social or economic
issues per se but that question I agree
can tell us a lot about the way we
approach issues that are related to
politics and culture and society so I
understand the inclusion of questions
like that right I mean the definition of
political science is as vague as the
study of human decisions so yes that's
an umbrella term right there
political compass org take it so I guess
that the big news is I am NOT I am NOT
an authoritarian leftist I am a
libertarian leftist are certainly much
more libertarian than authoritarian